[Music]  peih-gee has new insight into Jen  Aniston and Justin throws split a source  tells ET that early on the pair tried to  start a family and it obviously never  happened  adding quote but that is not why they  split they just kind of drifted apart  and there's no love lost between them  quote they have such love for each other  but they are both stuck in their own  particular lives Justin loves New York  and Jen's life is in LA I don't homebody  I pretty much stay home or I'll have a  dinner once in a while Wow with friends  now Jenna's in work mode and doesn't  want the break-up to derail her current  projects our source says she's not  looking to find romance again anytime  soon but loves having her friends as her  support system she's set to star in a  new TV project with Reese Witherspoon  for Apple yeah I'm excited  as the weather she'll get back together  with Brad Pitt our source says doubt it